not long after I released another
Sadler's stories video one of the
viewers asked an interesting question
talk about how you quit smoking and I
gave kind of a facetious answer at first
I said oh it's like super easy to quit
smoking I've done it dozens of times and
that that is quite true you know
quitting is easy staying quit is a much
more difficult task in part because
nicotine is so addictive and you have
all these other
associations let's call them positive
and negative with smoking cigarettes or
or in my case also cigars and I thought
it deserved a better answer a fuller
answer and so I'm going to tell the
story let's call it you know I was gonna
originally has to get tobacco use
because I also you know in addition to
smoking cigars and cigarettes I did try
uh chew at one time didn't really like
it I also tried snuff a couple times and
that didn't stick but it will just stick
with uh cigarettes and cigars so
um
you know I grew up in let's call it a
time and culture in place where smoking
was just ubiquitous you know my my
mother smoked for a long time my dad
smoked uh my grandfather on my dad's
side smoked uh my grandfather on my
mom's side smoked my uncle smoked you
know uh the ones who didn't used chew
you know various Forest snuff things
like that and you know the neighbors
smoked it was very very common to go
into
people's houses and there would be
ashtrays and you know people would sit
around and smoke while they they did
things and so you know we're talking
about in my case the 1970s and 1980s as
you say it was very prevalent you could
go into a bowling alley and there would
be people smoking as they're they're
bowling and drinking beer restaurants
typically would have a smoking section
and a non-smoking section but you know
the cigarette smoke would eventually go
over there you could go to McDonald's
and they actually had these tiny little
foil ashtrays that people would steal
Burger King had them as well and I
imagine probably every fast food joint
had them and you know ashtrays were kind
of a common gift to people we made
ashtrays in our Ceramics uh sections of
our art class for our parents who who
smoked back in elementary school and in
middle school so you know it was just
everywhere and you know uh it was It was
kind of tough as a non-smoker I remember
we would eat dinner and my mom and my
dad and Grandpa would all be smoking at
the dinner table while me and my sister
are you know sitting there and our eyes
are kind of watering and we'd you know
ask them not to smoke and they'd put
their cigarettes out and then you know a
little while ago by and they'd light up
again and people would smoke in the car
you know smoke out they were there were
ashtrays in the car cigarette lighters
in the car you could smoke on airplanes
so it was it was a very common thing and
I didn't actually start smoking
um despite the fact that many of my
friends and classmates did smoke uh
until I was 17. I did actually try
chewing tobacco
twice once my uncle gave me some to try
and you know I wasn't very experienced
with it and it kind of migrates in your
mouth another was on a camping trip with
a bunch of people from my high school
you know so they weren't allowed to
smoke but they were allowed to do chew
which is a little bit kind of a strange
contradiction there and I didn't like
that it wasn't my my thing and
you know I remember
like for example riding in the truck
with my uncle aim or being in the
basement of Grandpa and Grandma's House
Uncle aim had a whole wood shop down
there you know and he'd be smoking uh
while he was working on stuff or driving
and the smell was was kind of good
depending on what the the cigarettes
were right and and I I didn't want to
smoke myself but I kind of like that
tobacco smell
um you know and then when I was a
janitor I'd working in restaurants you'd
clean up people's messes that involved
cigarettes and then it didn't smell
quite so good but anyway I was working
in a restaurant I was working at a
Ponderosa and I got that job right after
I finished high school
before I went in the Army and I was I
was there for a number of months and you
know you have your co-workers and you
start to have some camaraderie with them
and uh I I just you know some of my
friends already smoked and I started
bombing a you know cigarette here and
there and taking a couple puffs and you
know I I enjoyed it that the sort of
constriction of your lungs and the
nicotine hitting you and then I was uh I
was
I guess you could say I was hooked right
and I started partaking in the kind of
rituals that people do when they smoke
and you know some of these are like
pairing it with certain drinks like you
wake up in the morning and you have a
you know a cup of coffee and you have a
cigarette with it right
um or you're you know drinking you're
having some some beers and you know
you're uh smoking while you're you're
drinking beer with people
well that was you know that was kind of
nice and
um you know that continued through and
eventually I started buying my own packs
instead of bumming them from people and
I will say this too cigarette smoking
was way way way cheaper back then there
were some taxes on it but not to the
extent that there currently are because
they've you know disincentivized it and
now you know people at that time knew
that smoking did uh raise your chances
for getting cancer some people were in
denial about it but it said it right
there on the back you know and this is
the time when some of the lawsuits were
beginning in the late 80s and all of
that sort of business uh but you know I
was enjoying myself and I found that it
didn't really interfere with my
lifestyle you know I was an incredibly
great shape at that time so smoking
didn't have any you know really negative
side effects on me at the that point and
then I went in the Army and going in the
Army so we couldn't smoke when we were
in basic training right except when of
course we got to go on leave I was a
combat engineer so basic and AIT were
combined into one big 13-week thing but
we got to go on you know a three-day
leave in between the two parts and I you
know we got cigarettes and beer and
liquor and had a good time right uh and
then I got got out and I was you know
ready to go to my duty station I went on
leave for a bit and of course you know
started smoking again and
um then I I went to Germany and when I
was in Germany and I was staying you
know on post if you went to the PX you
could buy cigarettes incredibly cheap
because there was no state tax right so
a curtain that's 10 packs of cigarettes
10 packs of 20 cigarettes would cost me
seven dollars now there was a
restriction you had a ration card you're
only allowed to buy four cartons a month
and then you had like a like 20
individual packs that you could buy but
you could always get somebody who didn't
smoke and use their ration card and so I
would do things like you know buy a
carton and we would generally like store
them in the refrigerator I'm not exactly
sure why I think we thought it would
keep it fresher and there was something
about like let's get a cool cigarette
out and light it up and you know it'll
it'll make the smoke you know nicer or
something we had all sorts of crazy
superstitions about that that sort of
stuff and you know
in the Army the people who smoke smoke a
lot because you've got you know you've
got a couple of minutes to kill well go
have a cigarette right and enjoy
yourself and when you're out in the
field doing exercises everyone would
have even the people who didn't smoke
would smoke and so you know it was a way
of building camaraderie it was a way of
like getting by uh and we would do crazy
crazy stuff like we would be on our five
mile run in the morning and somebody
would bring a pack of cigarettes with a
lighter in it and you know we young
people who smoked we would be running
and it was almost like a relay race
right so somebody would get out the pack
and they'd light it up and they'd take a
puff and then they'd hand it to the next
guy in front of him in formation and
he'd take it and he'd take a puff and
then he'd hand it to the next guy until
the cigarette was gone and the older
guys were all like oh you're gonna
regret that when you get older and we're
all like oh you old men we don't we
don't care about that we feel fine it's
not affecting us right and so you know
you did all that sort of stuff and then
if you went out to the bars and partied
or you're sitting around in the barracks
you'd smoke as well and so that really
reinforced the habit for me and then
when I got out you know and I went to uh
College actually I worked in in a
restaurant for a while before I went to
college
you know I continued that and again
buying cigarettes was easy cheap you buy
yourself a carton now would be a little
bit more expensive than in the Army but
it was still you know pretty uh
affordable and you had cigarette
machines in in bars and pool halls and
bowling alleys and hotels and you just
you know put your money in and get your
get your pack of cigarettes out and you
know I kind of experimented with smoking
different things I smoked Marlboros I
smoked camels for a little while I
smoked you know unfiltered Lucky Stripes
uh it while I was in the Army I tried
out menthols and you know I'd smoke
cools for a while or Newport or things
like that and you know each e-cigarettes
got its own kind of flavor I also smoked
Winston's which is what my dad and
grandpa had on my mom's side had smoked
and you know I didn't actually care for
them that much I stuck with the other
things as well and
um you know so this just kind of
continued and all you know a lot of my
friends smoked and then I remember this
is very interesting when I was in
college it was I think I want to say my
junior year the state of Wisconsin
passed a law you couldn't smoke in any
public buildings anymore you could still
smoke in bars or restaurants or places
like that but you couldn't smoke like as
we were doing in classrooms for example
where the lecturer you know the
discussion would end the class would be
over we'd all get our cigarettes up and
light up and chat with the professor
who's also smoking so that was that was
the end of that and we had to go outside
like a bunch of heathens you know in the
cold and we grumbled about it but then
after a while all that Haze cleared out
and we're like oh that must have been
really bad for the non-smokers you know
so anyway the the crowd that I ran with
you know we we uh smoked and drank and
partied and stuff like that I never got
into to pot because
well two reasons one was
um you know the few times that I tried
it I didn't find it that enjoyable and I
didn't like the taste and I also didn't
like the kind of dummies who were
smoking pot all the time it seemed to
make people kind of boring rather than
interesting you know drinking was my my
intoxicant of choice at the time and
smoking went along with drinking and you
know this continued on I I finished
College I came down here to Milwaukee
lived here for a year working and you
know smoking as well a way to kill time
a way to enjoy myself and then I went to
graduate school and in between uh I went
to Quebec I saved up some money you know
from my job went to Quebec and then went
to Europe and I was traveling around
Europe for about a month and a half or
so before I came back and then went to
graduate school and there you know I
started buying uh French galways
cigarettes which I really enjoyed as as
well that was that was kind of fun and
then you know I'm in graduate school and
you know still working out a lot I mean
I would actually do things like I would
have a cigarette in my mouth and I would
be jumping rope as I'm buffing away you
know or when we were jamming you know I
was playing bass in bands and stuff like
that in college uh you know you'd be
playing and you'd have a cigarette like
hanging out of your mouth or you'd be
writing a paper and you'd be you know
smoking away I should also mention too
when I tutored the Chinese students they
were all Heavy smokers as well and I
they would sometimes pay me by making
meals and sometimes they would just give
me packs of cigarettes right while I Was
preparing their lesson plans or things
like that so by the time that I get to
grad school I'm you know I'm smoking
quite a bit and I never like I mean if I
was partying I might smoke two packs in
a day and a night right or I was working
on a paper but I was generally about a
pack a day kind of smoker
and then while I was in grad school
things changed you know I started
instead of
smoking uh cigarettes that you would buy
in a pack I started getting into rolling
my own and you know I usually buy drum
and I would buy these big cans that cost
about 15 bucks and you get like I don't
know not thousands of cigarettes out of
them but hundreds of cigarettes out of
them and it was unfiltered and it was
higher quality tobacco you know it was
nice and moist and so it had a really
great mouth feel and uh you know that
that nicotine would hit you pretty hard
too right and you know I don't think I I
don't think at that time I actually did
try to quit smoking in any serious way
um
because I just enjoyed it and it wasn't
it wasn't really I mean you'd have like
that cough in the morning and uh stuff
like that but it wasn't having a huge
effect on me and I was getting more
pleasure than pain out of it you could
say and I enjoyed you know uh the the
things that went with it having like I
said that cup of coffee or a latte and
you know rolling your own cigarette and
having that together those two tastes
combining or having a nice meal and then
going outside with the other smokers to
to have a smoke together that was that
was kind of nice right and by this time
my mom had quit smoking my dad was long
gone my grandpa was was gone you know
grandpa lamris had also quit smoking by
that time so it was like a younger
people sort of thing and um
you know
eventually I got out of smoking tobacco
cigarettes and I started smoking instead
cigars and the way that ended up
happening was my friend Gary uh
uh we used to hang out a lot together he
was also a grad student in philosophy
and you know we were into some of the
same stuff and we'd chat a lot and hang
out and so anyway there was a tobacco
store in town in Carbondale and one day
we're sitting out in a beer garden you
know it's like afternoon and we're
drinking pitchers of beer and he's like
let's go get some cigars wouldn't that
be kind of cool kind of nice and I was
like yeah okay let's let's go and do
that and so we go to the store and and
they knew him there because he was
buying cigars and so I still you know I
started smoking cigars and I'm enjoying
that way way more than I'm enjoying uh
the cigarettes and so I stopped smoking
the cigarettes and I'd go and get myself
uh cigars you know and you and you can
get yourself like tins that have 10
cigars in them and you can buy yourself
big cigars and stuff like that and so
that's that continued on through through
grad school and
um you know I I really enjoyed that
quite a bit cigars there's so much more
complexity to The Taste you don't
generally inhale it all the way into
your lungs but you you still get that
buzz it's unfiltered it's a little bit
more expensive although you know
cigarette smoking has become very
expensive these days as well and that
continued on through graduate school I
graduated we moved to my family's land
in Indiana and then my Uncle Scott and I
were kind of like bad influences on each
other uh he lived right across the way
and we each got a humidor and we got
into this cigar club where we'd order
like you know you get like 25 cigars and
a batch and he'd be like hey uh try some
of these and I'd be like yeah yeah let's
let's uh try some of these that I got
too and we'd like compare notes and
stuff like that and I was you know I was
a smoking probably for like you know one
to two big Churchill cigars every day
because I enjoyed it so much you know
back then I was also Brewing my own beer
and you know those went really well
together and there was a lot of like
sitting outside and you know playing
music or doing things while smoking
reading books you know hanging out with
my uncles and chatting about stuff and
uh so that that continued on for for
quite a long time uh when I moved down
to Fayetteville I didn't take the big
humidor with me and I you know I would
occasionally Have a Cigar here and there
to sometimes buy these 10 pack of the
the smaller ones you know macanudos or
uh you know other other brands that you
would get and sometimes there'd be like
sales so you buy up a bunch of these and
that continued on for a long time and
then you know when I got involved with
my my wife
um you know we were both smoking
together which probably wasn't great for
our our pets uh but you know that it was
something that we we were doing and and
eventually you know she quit and
eventually I quit but it takes quite a
while when you are used to smoking to
really make that quit stick and you know
I think I haven't had a cigar now for
quite some time it got to the point
where I would only have one like on my
birthday
and I don't think I had one my last
birthday I still really do enjoy the
smell of a good cigar or even sometimes
tobacco smoke from a cigarette
I'm glad I quit I'm glad that I'm not
doing that because you know as you get
older it's really not good for your body
and in many many different ways you know
not just for your lungs but also your
your circulatory system and it's you
know it ages your face quite a bit but I
will say this it's it's not a struggle
to stay quit but I can see why people go
back and I really enjoyed smoking it was
such a social thing to do it's such a a
nice pleasure
um it's it's very expensive now I would
say even if you're purchasing things at
discount places and maybe that's a good
thing
um it's probably a good thing that less
younger people are smoking tobacco these
days but there there's also some things
that I really did enjoy about it
and you know I I do I have regrets I you
know it's
I could say that I regret spending all
of that time smoking but I I actually
don't
um and I actually the the effects on
health you know they're not that that
uh uh major for me I would say it's more
about the money that I spent that I
could have spent on other things instead
I certainly used smoking as a kind of
um Catalyst and sustainer
for my writing activities you know I
would sit and have have you know
cigarettes or sometimes I'd even just
like chew on a cigar you know and uh
work with that
um and and that was
kind of a crutch right but on the whole
you know do I do I regret the the years
that I spent smoking the decades not
really
um when I started up again
no probably not I mean I might enjoy a
cigar once in a very great while now
um but I wouldn't take it up again so
anyway that's a long story uh hopefully
this is satisfied some people's
curiosity about my references to
cigarettes and smoking that come up
every once in a while in other stories I
also use them as references sometimes
when I'm talking about Pleasures or even
addictions and prudence and things like
that in in my other philosophical videos
and uh you know
I'm sure some of you out there watching
this are smokers
um I'm not gonna like you know condemn
you or anything for it I'll just say
it's probably not not good for you and
there's other things that you can do
that you might get the same thrill or
kick or enjoyment out of or at least a
different one that's commensurate and
not quite as
hard on your body and not as expensive
but you know all things being equal it's
not the worst thing you could do in the
world so I'm gonna end it here otherwise
I might go on and on and on and say
that's that's pretty much the end of
this story